Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ricky from Charlotte.
Is that is that Charlotte, North Carolina,
I presume? Yes, it is. David, can you hear
me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: OK, awesome, thanks for taking
my call, so I wanted to ask you, I've kind
of noticed it seems to me like the right is
better at stigmatizing and demonizing words
and certain things are associated with the
left more than the left is. So just to give
like an example, you know, for decades they've
worked on demonizing the term socialism and
it's kind of stuck and all the like, you know,
left wing sort of economic schools of thought
like you would if you were just a normal,
normal person. You would think that, you know,
Marxism is synonymous with genocide or something
like that. But I just don't see the the left,
like, as doing as good of a job as like, you
know, demonizing a lot of ideas that are associated
with the white right. The only example I can
think of is like kind of demonize nationalism,
but I kind of see that they are trying to
revive that. What do you think?
Speaker 1: I completely agree with you and
you're not the only person to notice this.
George Lakoff has written about this to some
extent. Thomas Frank has written about this,
that this is you know, you go back to the
very basic framing of, for example, tax relief.
Tax relief is evil genius in a sense, right.
Where you relieve people of taxes. Taxes are
a burden. It's just tax burden. People you
get rid of taxes, you relieve the burden.
That is a completely absurd and myopic framing
of the fact that government needs to be able
to do things. And we have decided that we
don't do in most places a private fire department
or police department and roads and all these
different things. But the term tax relief
at a structural level pushes things in favor
of the right, and the left has to argue against
that. And they've done it with socialism.
They've done it with abortion, you know, pro-life.
I think that there are definitely opportunities
for the left to take to win the branding game.
You know, one example that this should have
started a year and a half ago, these Republicans
who are crazy about the pandemic, either they
don't want to deal with it in a serious way,
whatever they should start to be called pro
virus right there on the side of the coronavirus.
That's the way that it should be framed. And
if I if I'm the only one doing it, it's not
going to do anything. But if that had been
the framing for a long time, that when they
do these things, they are really on the side
of the virus, we may have been able to change
the trajectory even a little bit of the way
that the pandemic was dealt with. I think
there are opportunities, but you're completely
right that for the most part, the left is
not doing well on this issue of naming and
framing. Woops, I accidentally. I'm sorry
I accidentally muted you there. What were
you saying?
Speaker 3: Oh, sorry, can you hear me now?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can't. No, no, it was my
fault. I apologize.
Speaker 3: No problem. I was just going to
say the one more recent thing that I've noticed,
and it kind of made me mad ever since the
social justice protests last year. Yeah. A
bunch of these Boomer Republicans for the
first time heard the term WOAK and they've
done everything to demonize it. Like saying
that I like I really hate what's happened
to the term because I think back, it's not
a new thing. It's been around for a while
and it was always just about like, you know,
be conscious of it was about being conscious,
you know, like history, like understand like
how the systems work and everything and don't
just always fall for the mainstream narrative.
Now, you know, they've effectively demonized
it to where it just means like anything, you
know, that's like, you know, they'll call
any sort of climate change proposal. Woke
up this. And I feel like it's effective. And
it's just I like I hate how we're losing that
battle.
Speaker 1: It's the exact same thing that
happened with the progressive left where there
was a very brief period where Progressive
left really meant something or someone or
an idea that is ostensibly left. But it is
actually an authoritarian, regressive thing.
And for a very short period of time, it actually
worked to define and point to something. It
then just became bastardized by the right
and anything left they just called regressive.
That's so. So, yeah, they they're winning
on all fronts on that unfortunately.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well hopefully we can win
it. But I appreciate you taking my call. David,
you have a great day.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Thank you for calling
in. Great. Very important issue. No question
about that. Let's go next to Donnie from is
it pronounced Visalia, Visalia. How do you
pronounce it? They say Visalia, OK, good,
where is the.
Speaker 3: It's a central California Tarrant
County, about 45 minutes south of Fresno,
a beautiful area. Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, I've
been trying to get a hold of you let you know
about. I suspect I'm pretty sure that because
she was the 17th letter of the alphabet and
I know I heard stuff about Trump using 17
flags or something like that, but I believe
that's why he was always saying the 19 17
can this and send a shout out to CU supporters.
Speaker 1: Oh, that is fascinating. Let me
see if I understand this one. So. Q is the
17th letter of the alphabet. Is that true?
I'm taking your word for that.
Speaker 3: I mean, I haven't personally looked
it up, but it was at documentaries that I
think this
Speaker 1: is the third M is the 13th. So
m n o p Q would make it the 17th. Right. OK.
Q is the 17th letter of the alphabet, I guess.
Did Trump regularly have 17 American flags
on the stage or was that like once
Speaker 3: I had heard that. Well I don't
know. It might have been only once I heard
that he had did that once. But I believe that's
why he kept referring to the 1918 pandemic
as the 1917 pandemic. That's fascinating.
I mean, a shot outside of U.S. borders,
Speaker 1: it's probably not the case. He's
probably just an idiot. And he once said 1917.
And then he kept saying it because he can't
admit. But that's fascinating that that's
that that's a signal to queue that queue people.
That's funny. You're kind of going in and
out there, Donna. All right, I'm going to
let you go. Very, very funny instincts and
suggestion. The connection left a little bit
of something to be desired there. Let's
go next to Harpur from Marseilles, France.
Harper, you're on
the air.
Speaker 3: Hello. Oh, boy, I owe it to our.
Speaker 1: Harper, your connection's atrocious.
Oh, and Harper Harper already left Harper
Self selected out, either panicked or realized
or got disconnected.